hace un año el opositor alexéi navalni
llegó a suelo ruso tras meses
recuperándose de un envenenamiento en
alemania ese mismo día fue arrestado en
el aeropuerto acusado y condenado a dos
años y medio de prisión por incumplir la
libertad condicional ahora desde la
cárcel el ruso asegura que no se
arrepiente ni por un segundo de haber
vuelto a su país natal el año pasado
terriblemente rápido parece que fue ayer
cuando me subí a un avión con destino a
moscú ahora ya se ha cumplido un año la
verdad está escrita en los libros
científicos el tiempo en la tierra y el
espacio transcurren a velocidades
diferentes la condena provocó un aluvión
de críticas por parte de la comunidad
internacional que acusó al ejecutivo de
putin por faltar a la libertad de
expresión en el país un año después
organizaciones como amnistía
internacional siguen condenando los
hechos
el político sus simpatizantes y las
organizaciones de la sociedad civil rusa
han sufrido una implacable ofensiva de
represión la detención de navalny
también desencadenó manifestaciones
por el gobierno que también ilegalizó a
su movimiento por extremismo y
terrorismo desde el que apoyan al
disidente muchos en el exilio
el 17 de enero pasará sin duda la
historia como el día en el que comenzó
el fin del putinismo libertad para el
aek zeinab al nabhani que señala al
gobierno ruso porque estar su
envenenamiento con novillo que en
siberia está ahora a la espera de un
nuevo juicio en el que enfrentará a
cargos de terrorismo por los que podría
estar en prisión durante muchos años